it's so good yeah excuse me I'll see you
excuse me hi welcome back to tasting our
roots I'm Vanessa I had such an amazing
time training the different creole
spices and flavors from our previous
restaurant so we headed down to New
Orleans and hung out which have Eric
Benet from Uriel's we're doing a
Louisiana sell something Brits with a
barbecued butter sauce you have our
local pita beer how we use some fresh
garlic Creole seasoning we do food that
definitely has the Cajun Creole backbone
to it and with the Creole you have your
French your Spanish of course your
African this is a melting pot of all
these great cultures and all that great
labors and seasonings I'm so excited to
learn more about this dish let's get
cookin sounds good
we're gonna start with our beer
definitely not having that malt it's in
there the malt works very well with
Worcestershire sauce I don't really hear
a lot of combinations of butter and beer
and barbecue as far as like with shrimp
and grits so I'm interested to see how
the beer adds flavor to the dish hot
sauce lemon juice I'm gonna pour some
honey in there also we're gonna reduce
that down add some butter to it and then
we're gonna saute our shrimp a little
bit about Creole seasoning all right for
the grits and I'm sorry without a bit
clicks water heavy cream a little bit of
salt and pepper
and we're gonna let this come up to a
boil and I think it just plays into our
our southern culture down here using
grits that we have them leave them all
the time are there any other starts
alternative rice mashed potatoes were
working on awesome
bread you like a po-boy let's come on
Phillip oil and now we're gonna whisk in
our grits and at this time you want to
keep on whisking until it comes back up
to the boil the inspiration for this
dish is our version of barbecued butter
unlike your toosh mill barbecue sauces
that have our tomato base ours is
definitely based on the local beer so
now the sauce is a nice and bubbly it's
reduced
I like to see large bubbles and then
right in the center some small bubbles
and we're gonna add some heavy cream to
that and that's it for the cream those
are the two tablespoons let that reduce
down again see the bubbles are starting
to come around the outside of the pot
you can tell that is getting nice and
thick and actually if I take my spoon
here you can see that it's sticking up
quite a bit take your finger but leave
the wine just like that you're pretty
much ready to go what is the difference
between the Creole and Cajun Creole
you're gonna find actually a little bit
more of our tomato product definitely
more of the use of your spices in Africa
Cajun was the opinions coming down from
the Canada and so basically they
wouldn't get a lot of one pot dishes but
they were using a lot of stuff to pick
out in the land and so that's where your
gumbo is come from have the consumer in
a pot right now we're getting ready to
wish the butter enzyme reducing the heat
down to low and like we said before just
nice and slow and we're gonna put one
chunk in at a time and just let that
incorporate into the sauce we want to
keep it low and slow
so basically we're making an emulsion
and emulsions or sauces like aa VNA's
honey mustard or like a ranch dressing
evening a little couple of chunks of
butter still there I like to turn the
heat off and just finish whiskey in
there and I think we're just about done
one thing we can't overlook it of course
is our gulf shrimp you have the ability
to get shrimp here daily or add the Gulf
and delivered to us of our two hours
after there you are caught we're going
to take our fresh gulf shrimp into this
nice hot pan give a sprinkling of some
Creole seasoning chopped garlic and a
little bit of fresh rosemary
they're gonna move that around so you
don't know just finishing sautéing the
shrimp flipping them over making sure
put the course on both sides they start
to curl up a little bit but they're
still nice and plump you don't want to
overcook your seafood so now the shrimp
for a pretty much cook they cook very
quickly we're gonna turn off the heat
what about the culture of the food made
you stay here oh definitely it's just
the raw to be yeah joy of life and just
permeates your soul on just like the way
your seasoned food like that you may
have a great word down here called lania
and a lot of times when people come in
to eat we offer them a little Langat
plate which means a little extra when I
kick the seasoning just put it a little
bit more push finish the grits off with
a little bit of butter stir that right
in and some Parmesan cheese that that's
all incorporated he can add some of it
grits to the bowl uh if you like yours a
little bit thinner definitely just add a
little bit more water
in the bowl and we are laying them on
the grits
rosemary spread and then some green
onions right a little bit ah thank you
so much yeah thank you so much for
letting us come the murals I learn all
about your dish I'm so excited to try
the flavors with a BBQ beer size and how
it mixes in with all the spices and I'm
going to eat this there's a pleasure
happy thank you I'm gonna try the the
grits with the barbecue butter sauce
it's super creamy and you just kind of
get the taste of the grits the furled
texture and then you have at this burst
of flavor with the sauce this is such a
classic dish it's like good time because
it's like good time is all about like
family all right it's just so you have
to come try this is definitely more
simpler dish to do like he only used a
few pans and even though it's a little
more low in flow it's definitely not
over complicated so when people think of
New Orleans and they say come to New
Orleans for the food this is the food
they're talking about a whole meanness
creaminess the the good feeling that you
get this is New Orleans like flavor so
that's it for us here at Mariel's thank
you to chef Eric and the entire murals
team for having us and thank you for
watching tasting our roots
you
[Music]